welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman trailer is
filled with clues many of us are
scratching our heads over some of us
scratching so hard it's looking like
we're pulling out our hair and we get
haircuts mid video
but beneath these bloody murders and
cryptic wordplay by this movie's the
riddler
is what many comic book readers consider
to be a grander conspiracy by a network
known as the court of
owls who the hell are they if you don't
read the comics
trust me there is a much deeper reason
die hards are excited for the court of
owls other than that new gotham knights
game trailer that dropped
or the reason i'm fascinated with all
things related to birds those twitchy
egg poop and feather angels
in this video i'm going to explain what
the court of owls
is why they are so important to the dc
world and
how they could sink their talons into
this robber patterns in batman story
spoiler warning in case i accidentally
decode the riddler's seventh riddle in
this movie i'm kind of moving through
them fast
okay so the court of owl's speculation
began with the sighting of the riddler's
first clue left at the crime scene in
the trailer
depicting an owl on the cover of that
card this
plus a ton of other clues that i don't
have time for in this video i'm going to
break down in the next one
has led to speculation that behind the
riddler's killings
is an attempt to expose the court of
owls as the
shadowy cabal controlling gotham city so
the court of owls has become a favorite
batman villain since 2011 when they
emerged in the new 52 comics
this reboot batman was now only five
years into being a vigilante in gotham
so he
assumed that he knew the city in and out
but there was still
a lot about gotham that he did not know
by the way this might correspond with
the batman director matt reeves
insistence
that his story is a year two story not
an origin story but a story set
early enough in batman's life so that he
can still be caught off guard by secrets
lurking on the other side of his
slightly elevated collar the court of
owl's run begins with the discovery of a
corpse pinned to a wall with these
blades and an autopsy reveals that in
his tooth as a filling
imprinted with an image of an athenian
owl which is a symbol of wealth and
power
dating back to ancient greece and again
yes there are owl sightings that i think
are just like this in the batman trailer
they're very easy to miss and there's a
lot to go through just keep an eye out
for that video where it goes through
them all
gordon and batman recall a nursery rhyme
they heard as kids
kind of urban legends spread around the
youth of gotham and the rhyme went as
follows
beware the chords of owls that watches
all the time
ruling gotham from a shadowed perch
behind
granite and lime they watch you at your
hearth
they watch you in your bed speak not a
whispered word of them or they'll send a
talon
for your head yeah batman thinks this is
a crock of [ __ ]
until as bruce wayne he meets with
mayoral candidate and city leader
lincoln march kind of a parallel to
bruce wayne idealist figure with
big plans to revitalize gotham when wow
a talent comes for his head
an assassin named talent who slashes at
him and tries to kill them both
lincoln says that the court of owls is
targeting him because his plans
contradict their interests for the city
and that they left a nest filled with
bones at his house a nest of bones a
detail i didn't find too weird since i
went through a phase in which i was
leaving that around my house as a kid i
wanted to be a bird oh and by the way
it's worth noting that this batman
trailer also
opens with the assassination of the
city's mayor but i think there's a twist
involved there okay so in the comic
batman applies his awesome detective
skills and ends up researching his
ancestor
alan wayne kind of a nutso allen wayne's
trust built a number of the buildings in
the gotham skyline
and like many architects he had a
superstition that involved him skipping
the 13th floor in the building's
construction which batman discovers
resulted
in the court of owls using the 13th
floor of these buildings
as hideouts for their talon executioners
batman ends up getting trapped by the
court in their creepy labyrinth that
starts to drive him insane
and we learn during this process the
court of owls has been running gotham
for centuries they've been using
endless resurrected incarnations of
talon deploying talon to assassinate
figures who go against their control of
the city
and propping up the various city leaders
to do their bidding and when people
don't comply they trap them in this
labyrinth who terrify them into
submission among their many victims over
the ages could have been thomas and
martha wing
war breaks out between batman and the
courts at one point batman does track
them down but
finds them all dead via apparent suicide
but they're actually homicidely poisoned
by latest talon lincoln march
suggested to be bruce's secret brother
thomas wayne jr
but bruce and we the readers are left
guessing as to what
the truth really is so how could this
amazing comic tie into the plot of the
batman as we know it in the movie look i
know there's a lot of clues we gotta
sift through
because the best visual clues are hiding
in plain sight just like someone's front
pocket wallet like the ridge
thanks to the ridge for sponsoring this
episode the ridge helps you carry what
you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack
they want you to make the most out of
what you're bringing with you the ridge
wallet is made out of military-grade
materials like titanium and carbon fiber
it has a clean stylish design it is
so when jason voorhees is trying to kill
you he won't be able to kill your credit
cards this is their aluminum silver
wallet they do have other colors
including some very flashy tiki designs
this thing is light it's strong just
like you
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee
it's also got thirty thousand five star
reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocky pockets and the optional device
charging batteries
hit 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description okay so when it
comes to the quarter vowels in this
upcoming batman film
we have gotten a number of parallels and
visual clues pointed out that owl card
there are some even cooler ones that
were harder to spot
and i will get to those but for now i
just want to talk about the three ways i
could see the court of owls playing out
in the story as we know it to be the
first way it could go
perhaps this edward nashton riddler is
this movie's version of talon
an assassin secretly working on behalf
of the court assassinating those who
pose a threat to their rule of the city
and his clues taunting the batman and
his references to justice could be an
extension of the creepy taunting from
the court
but i'm laying against that theory only
because the court of owls are much more
discreet
they wouldn't murder the mayor and the
d.a in big public spectacles
and they would not leave behind an
obvious ass clue with a big dumb owl on
it also this mayor was re-elected for a
third term he's been in power for a
while
he's been doing lots of stuff busting up
the moroni crime family i'm guessing
this mayor would have been one that the
court approved of a puppet that they put
in place and that killing him was an
attempt to expose the court
so a second way i see this going the
riddler knows about the court's
existence and his murders are an attempt
to
uproot their corruption from the city of
gotham and bring in batman to help with
this cleansing process
hiding his messages in clues that only
the world's greatest detective could
understand
as i will explain the other video the
two riddles we know about so far from
the riddler depict
an owl and allude to a court those hints
plus
taking out those in charge of the city
cannot be good for the owl's dominion of
it but i also don't think the riddler is
that interested in batman's help he's
clearly an
antagonist to the batman and you don't
have to look too much further than the
fact that he tries to blow him up in a
church but that brings me to the third
direction i think this court of owl's
adaptation will go
and hold onto your butts the final
exchange of this trailer
hints that batman himself is involved in
this conspiracy
too how am i part of it
you'll see and during the dc fandom
trailer reeves suggested that the wayne
family was part of this corruption
so you start to see that as it starts to
describe this
epic history of corruption in gotham
that you start to understand well
where did my family sit in that again
since this batman story is not an origin
but rather one that begins with batman
already in the middle of being a violent
vigilante does this batman even know
how he got started doing this i'm
vengeance
and those chaos bringing street punks
fear him he
is the boogeyman that they tell
themselves ghost stories about i suggest
that this
batman without realizing it might be
carrying out the will of the court of
owls
a talon type patsy executioner who
claims to be justice
but for a court of lies all the
detective work the case is given to him
are all coming from a corrupt hierarchy
a corrupt mayor a corrupt d.a a corrupt
police commissioner all put in place by
a corrupt cabal
trying to maintain their vision of order
in the city using
this dark knight as an enforcer this
could be a life of vengeance that bruce
inherited after his parents death a last
will and testament carried out by andy
circus as alfred pennyworth who has said
the relationship between bruce and
alfred will be
a key part of this story batman is the
one who watches you in your hearth
he is the one who watches you in your
bed and if you whisper a word about him
he'll send a talon for your head
and the riddler's clues could be an
attempt to expose to batman
the lords he has actually been serving
that is the blindness
referred to by the riddler's words what
is the price
for your blind trust me
there are a lot of visual owl clues that
back this up we're gonna go deeper into
this
in the next video stay tuned in the
meantime follow me on instagram
ea boss follow new rockstars subscribe
to this channel and hit that
notification bell so you'll be there
when the video comes out
thanks for watching batman
[Music]
you